>> ♪ ♪
>> REPUBLICAN SENATOR RON
JOHNSON CALLED OUT NBC'S CHUCK
TODD TO "MEET THE PRESS" AFTER
PRESSING HIM ON INVESTIGATIONS
INTO THE BIDEN'S FAMILY'S SHADY
BE DEALERS.
THINGS GOT TESTY.
>> DO YOU HAVE A CRIME THAT YOU
THINK HUNTER BIDEN COMMITTED?
IT'S NOT A CRIME TO MAKE MONEY
OFF YOUR LAST NAME.
>> SO, CHUCK, YOU OUGHT TO READ
THE MARCO POLO REPORT WHERE THEY
DETAILS ALL KINDS OF CRIMES.
>> HOLD ON.
I NEED TO STOP YOU THERE.
>> HOLD ON A SECOND.
>> POTENTIAL.
>> WITH $30,000.
CHUCK, IS IT A CRIME TO BE
SOLICITING PROSTITUTION IN
EUROPEAN SEX TRAFFICKING
SITUATION.
>> YOU SEEM TO HAVE A PATTERN.
I AM A JOURNALIST.
I DEAL IN FACTS.
>> CHUCK, PART OF THE PROBLEM
AND THIS IS OBVIOUS TO ANYBODY
WATCHING.
YOU DON'T INVITE ME ON TO
INTERVIEW ME.
INVITE ME ON TO ARGUE WITH ME.
>> YOU CAN GO BACK INTO YOUR
PARTISAN CABLE COCOON.
>> I AM A JOURNALIST.
I ONLY DEAL IN FACTS.
I HAVE NOT SEEN ANY EVIDENCE AT
ALL.
I HAVE LOOKED REALLY HARD FOR
EVIDENCE OF HUNTER BIDEN.
>> ANYONE WHO HAS LOOKED AT THE
BIDEN TEAM DEALINGS WITH
OBJECTIVITY KNOWS THERE IS
A HOST OF POTENTIAL WRONG DOINGS
IN THE OPEN.
AS JONATHAN TURLEY WRITES:
TODD HEAPS INSULTS ON THOSE
CALLING FOR INVESTIGATION.
HE GAVE SUPPORTIVE INTERVIEWS
FOR INVESTIGATING THE
COMPROMISING OF DONALD TRUMP.
AND ADDS ABOUT THE BIDENS.
FROM ARE FOREIGN TRANSFERS,
GIFTS AND OTHER MATTERS THAT
COULD PROVE CRIMINAL.
IT GETS EVEN WORSE FOR HUNTER.
HE IS FIGHTING TO PREVENT HIS
DAUGHTER WITH HER EX-LOVER FROM
USING HIS LAST NAME.
HUNTER'S LEGAL TEAM IS TRYING TO
STOP THE REQUEST TO LET THE
4-YEAR-OLD SAKE THE BIDEN NAME.
HERE IS THE WISCONSIN SENATOR
RON JOHNSON.
THANKS FOR BEING HERE.
HE HAD THE GALL TO COME OUT AND
SAY I HAVE YET TO SEE ANY
EVIDENCE.
HAS HE LOOKED?
WHY WON'T HE TAKE SERIOUSLY
THOSE WHO HAVE AND REALIZE THE
CONNECTION BETWEEN HUNTER AND
JOE IS NOT JUST A CONNECTION
BETWEEN 2 PRIVATE CITIZENS BUT
A PRIVATE CITIZEN AND THE
PRESIDENT?
?
>> WELL, PETE FYOU DON'T LOOK
FOR EVIDENCE YOU WILL NEVER FIND
IT.
BUCK MADE A GOOD POINT IN THE
PREVIOUS SEGMENT -- COUNTERS WHO
HELPED INSTALL PRESIDENT BIDEN
INTO HIS OFFICE.
THEY CALL HIM A MODERATE.
THEY CENSORED MY REPORT ON THE
HUNTER BIDEN LAPTOP STORY.
THEY DON'T WANT TO DEFENDING HIS
RECORD.
INFLATION AND ON THE OTHER HAND
AND RISING CRIME.
I AM SUSPICIOUS ABOUT THE
REVELATION OF THESE DOCUMENTS.
FOUND THEM LAST NOVEMBER AND
HAVE A DRIP, DRIP, DRIP
REVELATION OF THESE THINGS
COMING OUT.
IT'S AN ABSURD STORY.
MAKES NO SENSE WHATSOEVER.
THE JOURNALISTS DON'T WANT THE
EGG ON THEIR FACE.
THEY DON'T WANT TO DEFEND THIS
PRESIDENT.
HIS POLICIES ARE A DISASTER FOR
THIS COUNTRY.
>> SUSPICIOUS OF WHO MIGHT HAVE
WANTED THESE REVELATIONS TO COME
OUT AND THE REASON FOR THAT?
>> YES, IT'S A BIZARRE STORY.
IT MAKES NO SENSE WHATSOEVER.
IF YOU FOUND THESE DOCUMENTS AND
YOU WERE WORKING FOR THE
PRESIDENT.
WOULD GO TO THE PRESIDENT.
IF THE PRESIDENT WANTED TO
DISCLOSE IT HE WOULD LOOK IN
EVERY NOOK AND CRANNY AND FIND
ANY CLASSIFIED DOCUMENTS AND
RELEASE THE STORY ALL AT ONCE.
THEY WOULD NOT SAY OH WE FOUND
MORE DOCUMENTS IN THE GARAGE OR
IN A DRESSAR DRAWER.
IT'S A BIZARRE STORY -- IT MAKES
NO SENSE.
>> CHUCK TODD DO YOU THINK HE
EVER MAKES AN ERNEST EFFORT TO
UNDERSTAND ANY OTHER SIDE THAN
HIS HOME TEAM?
HE CALLS HIMSELF A JOURNALIST.
HE BELIEVES HE IS SOMEWHERE IN
THE MIDDLE.
ARE THEY DELUSIONAL OR LIVED IN
THE COCOON FOR TOO LONG?
>> UNFORTUNATELY YOU HAVE THE
VAST MAJORITY OF PEOPLE IN THE
MAINSTREAM MEDIA.
THEY ARE NOT JOURNALISTS
ANYMORE.
THEY ARE ADVOCATES FOR THE
DEMOCRAT PARTY.
THEY SEE THINGS FROM A SLANTED
VIRAC THE VIEWPOINT OF THE LEFT.
THEY DON'T BELIEVE THERE IS ANY
OTHER VIEWPOINT THAT IS VALID.E.
OTHER VIEWPOINT THAT IS VALID.
FOX NEWS AND AS FAIR AND
BALANCED AS YOU CAN GET.
YOU PRESENT BOTH SIDE.
THE MAINSTREAM DOESN'T DO THAT.
>> NOPE.
"MEET THE PRESS" HIS OWN
PERSONAL COCOON FOR MANY YEARS.
YOU DID THE WORK.
IT WAS SUPPRESSED AN